- What do we got here?
A 1936 [inaudible]
Zeiss camera.
Sweet.
And where did you get this?
We do clean outs for
different storage facilities.
And for his pay for the
day, this is what he wanted.
OK.
So how old are you?
14.
You know, they were
still using these things
when I was 14.
The camera I'm
coming in to sell today
is a 1936 Zeiss movie camera.
We know very little
about this movie camera.
But it's really cool.
The appraiser that we
went to said that he
has never seen one of these.
He's only seen two.
Sorry.
This is really neat.
So you have a Zeiss
16 millimeter camera.
I looked it up some
for like, 20 minutes
and said, can't
find nothing on it.
Kodak came out with 16
millimeter early 1920s,
and they were
hoping that it would
be a home movie camera, OK?
The problem was it was
really damn expensive.
Most people-- 99% of
people in this country
couldn't afford it.
But news organizations loved
them, because you could run
around, get a news
story, and you
could sell it to the newsreels.
Anyone who has gone to
film school at one point
probably used a 16
millimeter camera.
It's an incredible pain
to load, develop film,
and everything else.
But it makes incredible images
that you still, to this day,
cannot get on video.
Why are you selling it?
We do demolition derbies,
and I was hoping to get
enough for me to buy a car.
- OK.
You ever tried it?
No.
It's the most fun you can
have with your clothes on.
What were you looking
to get out of it?
At least $800.
You know, you've got a
really interesting camera here.
Everything is in great shape,
looks like it was barely used.
But the problem is they just
don't go for that much money,
because there's so
many of them out there.
I mean, you know, once
the video came out,
all these things
threw on a shelf.
Well we went to
an appraiser for it,
and he said he
has only seen two.
And he said the first one he
saw looked like it had got hit
by a truck, and it was $250.
OK, well, see, this is one
of the things about this world.
People can ask for
money all day long,
it's whether they get it or not.
I'll give you 100 bucks for it.
Nah, we'll do a
little better than that.
I think $100 is
really insulting.
Bottom dollar will be $400.
No.
Unfortunately, it's not here.
No one uses these anymore.
I am being a nice guy offering
100 bucks because it will sit
around for a very long time.
I don't think I'm going
to be able to do that.
OK.
Well, thanks for
coming in, though.
I'm going to take
the camera home,
and probably put it on a
shelf, and wait 20 years.
Not a big deal.
He'll hustle something else.